hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the top six
checkmates that you need to know
to improve your win percentage we're
going to be focusing on
middle and late game patterns that lead
to
these checkmates so without further ado
let's get into the list of the top six
checkmates
coming in at number six is the arabian
mate which has
the knight and the rook teaming up for a
nice checkmate
the rook can come to g8 in this example
the king can't take the rook it's
protected by the knights
and it can't come to the h7 square
because that square is also
attacked by the knight
in this example the white knight and the
rook
team up for arabian mate with rook to
g8 checkmate the king can't move even if
the rook here on h7
was not there that square is blocked off
by the knight
on f6 so white should do everything in
their power
to get to this position
if we come back just a few moves it's
white's turn
and white can play the move queen to h6
there's only two legal moves the king
can't move because this knight here on
f6
is blocking the g8 square so black can
move over with this rook on h7 but as we
already looked at
this is arabian mate right here with
rook 2 g8
that's checkmate or the other option is
to play bishop to h7
and then white has a queen sacrifice
queen takes here
the king cannot recapture because of the
knight the rook is forced to recapture
and this is the position that white's
trying to get to because you have that
pattern recognition of knowing how to
set up the mates
white now is able to sacrifice material
and
has arabian mate here with rook 2 g8
coming at number 5 we have bowdoin's
mate which involves
two bishops attacking the king which
usually is castled on the queen side
and the bishops do all the work you
don't need any other pieces
in this example white can play to move
bishop to a6
checkmate in this example you can see
the white king is castled on the queen
side
black very nicely has the light square
bishop here on f5
which is attacking all of these light
squares reducing the number of moves
that the white king can move now black
can play the move bishop to a3
and bowden's mate takes effect white is
checkmated
the king cannot move so black should do
everything in their power
to reach this position
as we take a step back one move we can
see that it's black's move
and black has the move queen takes here
on c3 setting up
boden's mate the king is under attack
and can't come to b1
because that square is attacked by the
bishop here on f5
the only legal move is to take with the
pawn on c3
and now black has the move bishop to a3
checkmate so anytime your opponent
castles on the queen side
see if you can maneuver your bishops
to set up bowden's mate
coming in at number four we have the
opera mate where the bishop and rook
combine
for a nice checkmate on the opponent's
king
you can see the bishop here on g5 is
attacking these dark squares
and is also protecting the square here
on d8
the rook can come to d8 and the king
can't move along this eighth rank and it
also can't come to the e7 square because
the bishop
it's blocked in by the pawn here on f7
which could really be any piece except
for a knight which could then capture
the rook here
and so in this position the black king
is checkmated
the best example to show the opera mate
is to show the famous game
that actually gave this checkmate its
name and that is
from the 1858 famous game between
paul morphy the american chess master
and two strong
amateurs they played this at an opera
house in
paris paul murphy playing the white
pieces
play the move bishop takes on d7
check forking the queen the strong
amateurs not wanting to lose their queen
with queen takes on d7
and then losing to rook takes on d7
instead played the move knight takes on
d7
you can see that this opens up for the
bishop here on
g5 to attack all of these squares here
on
this dark diagonal and also opening up
for
the rook to eventually come to d8
all paul morphy now had to do is play
the move queen to
b8 check
the knight takes here on b8
no other options here and once the
knight's out of the way paul morphy was
able to play
the opera mate which did not have the
name at the time
but play the move rook to d8 checkmate
coming in at number three we have
anastasia's mate which involves the
knight
and the rook trapping the opponent's
king on the side of the board
white has the move rook to h3 and you
can see
that the knight blocks off the squares
g8 and g6
and the rook here on h3 blocks off the
move
h6 and h8 and this is checkmate
back in 2003 magnus carlson used the
anastasia's mates
to surprise his opponent with checkmate
you can see in this example he has his
knight here on e2
perfectly placed to block off the g1
and the g3 squares from the king all he
needed to do was to bring his rook here
on e4 over to the h file and it would be
checkmate so magnus carlsen sacrificed
his queen by playing queen
to h5 the only legal move for white
is to take with the pawn that frees open
the rook to now come
to h4 and magnus carlson was able to
checkmate using
anastasia's mate
coming in at number two we have the back
rank mates
one of the most common mating patterns
that you will see
and that is when your opponent has their
king on the back rank
for black that's going to be the eighth
rank for white that's going to be on the
first rank here
they've usually castled they're behind
their pawns so it does seem like
it's safe but then
you can see here white can play rook to
b8
and the king is under attack and has
nowhere to go
could only move along this eighth rank
anyway
and so you have the back rank mate
many times the back rank mate has
allowed a player to get the checkmate
even when it looks like all hope is lost
you can see in this position black is
clearly winning
looking to checkmate the opponent in the
next couple moves
but it's white's move and white knows
that the backrank mate is
unavoidable they can play rook to
b8 and all black can do is
delay the inevitable and that is to
first play bishop to
c8 after the rook takes here check
then the queen comes to d8 after the
rook takes
where it comes up here to e8 and black
continues to lose material
and at the end of it the king is still
trapped
behind the pawns here on this eighth
rank in white wins oven
even though they were down a ton of
material with the back rank mate
before we get into the final checkmate
if you haven't already
if you wouldn't mind please hitting the
like button
also curious in the comments below what
your favorite
checkmate pattern is to use in
a chess game so without further ado
let's get into
the final checkmate and that is going to
be
the smothered mate the reason i had this
number one is
if you've ever pulled it off it's just
one of the most satisfying things
in all of chess and the most simplistic
way to
show it is in this example white can
play the move knight
to f7 and you can see the king here on
h8 is completely surrounded
by its own pieces and it cannot move in
this case
black loses the game
sometimes it takes a few moves to set up
the smother mate but if you can actually
pull it off it's well worth it in the
end
white would really like it if the rook
here was on g8
in that case white could just play
knight to f7 and that would be a
smothered mate
so the goal in this position is to get
black to move his rook here to
g8 white can do this by first starting
out with
knight 2 f7 check king is forced to move
to
g8 the only legal move and then knight
to
h6 this is double check both the knight
and the queen are attacking the king
and the king is forced to move anytime a
king is in double check they have to
move they can't come to
f8 so the king has to come back to
h8 now the main difference with the
knight here on h6
is it is defending and attacking this
square here
on g8 the king can't move there
and so white has the move queen to g8
this is check but since the king can't
take it it's defended by the knight
black is forced to take with the rook
here on g8 and now
white has forced the rook to come to g8
trapping the king
and white can deliver the final blow
with knight to f7
hopefully everyone enjoyed this list of
the top six
checkmates that you should know if
there's other lists you'd like me to
make
please let me know in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching the
video
and i'll see you next time
you